[Music]
in today's business environment data is
a necessity
this course will give you an
understanding of data science so you
think beyond just spreadsheets and
tables we will use real-world case
studies to help you understand common
methodologies in statistics
data analytics and data science
along with some basic skills on how to
apply them to your everyday work
the role of statistical analysis and
data analytics is to provide you with
conversation starters
we will dive into data wrangling
visualization
forecasting and even machine learning
you will learn how to design visual
models develop hypotheses and draw
insights into actionable recommendations
for your business what you need to know
as a data science analyst is that you
have to always be ready to change your
model
this will be taught through case studies
from retail
healthcare
financial institutions
and even hollywood
i really wanted to understand the data
because producing a film can be costly
but even more costly sometimes can be
actual advertising not only will you
gain the awareness of the technical
elements of data analysis
this course will give you the tools and
the methodologies to act upon the
results you can actually maximize the
performance at the individual level and
in aggregate you will get a better
performance for the company can you
predict the future for your business
you